[موسيقى]
يعلن برنامج الغذاء العالمي ان مخزونه
ينفذ في شمال غرب سوريا ويدعو الى فتح
مزيد من المعابر الحدوديه من تركيا بعد
الزلزال ووجه البرنامج مناشده من اجل
الحصول على 77 مليون دولار لتقديم
المساعده لنحو
874 الف متضرر في تركيا وسوريا يشمل ذلك
284 الف نازح جديد في سوريا
و590 الف نازح في تركيا بينهم خمسه
واربعون الف سوري يشار الى ان 90% من سكان
شمال غرب سوريا البالغ عددهم اربعه ملايين
واربعمائه الف شخص يعتمدون على المساعدات
الانسانيه يوفر البرنامج المساعدات
الغذائيه لاكثر من 4 ملايين شخص في شمال
غرب سوريا من بين نحو سته ملايين ونصف
مليون شخص يتلقون المساعدات من البرنامج
في جميع انحاء سوريا اما بالنسبه لعدد
يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي في سوريا
قبل الزلزال فيقدره البرنامج باكثر من 12
مليون شخص ويقدر عدد النازحين قبل الزلزال
بنحو سته ملايين وثمانمائه الف شخص